Rossi, what's our next story?
Well, for anyone out there dating
but feeling just a little bit stuck
could it be that you're groundhogging?
Let me explain.
Stylist reports that groundhogging
is when you are stuck in a cycle
of dating the same type of person over and over.
And we know we've all been there
and it just ends up disappointing.
A lot of people say they have a type
based on a physical appearance or something
or career path.
But according to the dating app, Inner Circle,
"Four out of five people say
dating their type is not working for them."
Girl, wake up, it's not working.
So this sounds like you experts say
it's time to start thinking out of that box, right?
Surprise yourself, try a date with someone
who doesn't match your usual type or your criteria,
just to see how it goes.
I love this idea.
I love this so much.
Because what do you have
to lose if you try something?
Nothing!
Exactly, thank you.
Isn't the definition of insanity
doing the same thing over and over again,
expecting a different result?
Have you ever found yourself
sort of dating the same type of person
and getting the same result?
When I was younger, absolutely.
Yeah.
I think I was the groundhog too.
I was stuck in the same patterns.
Yeah.
I just was like fun, sexy.
"Let's drink, let's party, let's travel, let's play."
It was more hedonistic, less sustainable.
Oh, uh-huh, uh-huh, uh-huh.
But I'm glad I did it 'cause now I'm so sustainable.
Yes you are.
And less hedonistic.
Totally.
So the tables turn,
I don't think we necessarily groundhog in our own life.
I love when people know that they're capable of change
and people are capable of change
so anybody who wants to turn a cycle
or break a pattern, you can.
Absolutely, you can!
Absolutely.
I've seen the evidence of it with my own behaviors.
I've seen it in other people.
So if you are groundhogging
and you would like to break that cycle,
it's all up to you.
You can, but I love saying that you're groundhogging
if you are sort of doing the same thing over and over again
it makes so much sense.
And I love the suggestion
of going outside your typical
person that you're drawn to or type.
I always also find it shocking when women are like,
"He's too short."
I'm like, "Who cares.
Is he nice?"
Oh who cares, hello!
What's his FICO score?
Girl, let's talk.
You know what I mean?
Exactly!
Who cares about height.
If you're a short, nice guy.
Yes.
Any day of the week, don't cry, no!
Absolutely, yeah. if you're groundhogging,
you better stop or the only thing you're gonna see
is your shadow by yourself, alone.
Ooh.
(audience claps)
So switch it up.
Absolutely, well, before we go a friendly reminder,
that now you can take us on the go
with the Drew Barrymore Show podcast.
Oh, hey!
That's right, you can listen to the whole show,
every weekday just look for us wherever you pod.
And we'll be right back.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪